FEMALE SPEAKER: Thanks
everyone for coming.
So this is Nathan.
And he is the co-founder
and Creative Director
at "Roadtrip Nation."
And he started his first road
trip back in 2001, I believe.
NATHAN GEBHARD: 2001.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So he's going
to tell you a little bit more
about his current
book, "Roadmap."
And he has a few co-authors
with them today as well.
We'll go through
his presentation.
If you have questions,
there's time at the end.
And then there's books
available for a book signing.
And you can come talk to him
and the other authors as well.
So thank you.
NATHAN GEBHARD: Sweet.
Well, thanks for
coming, you guys.
I'm going to kind
of just walk you
guys through the
story of "Roadtrip
Nation" and our new book.
And as Caroline said before,
we've got a few co-authors here
that will join us.
So Alyssa, Jamie,
Willie, and Annie
will come up on to the
stage for the Q&A part.
So just to give you a
little sense of "Roadtrip."
When people ask,
what is "Roadtrip",
what do you guys do, this
is the simple sentence.
We create experiences
that empower
individuals to build livelihoods
around their interests.
And I think it took us a while
to put that sentence together
and to really feel
comfortable with it
because I think the underlying
piece is that it really
came from a much more rough and
uncertain question, which was,
what am I going to
do with my life?
So in 2001, myself and two other
co-founders, Mike and Brian,
were about ready to
graduate from college
and just realized we
were sitting there
in a situation where the lives
that we were about to lead
were not our own.
So Mike was a double major--
biology kinesiology major.
He had always thought he
was going to be a doctor.
His entire family was
a family of doctors.
And through one internship,
he realized he hated hospitals
and that that was just
not going to be his life.
Brian was about to become
third generation in a family
business.
So he was able to
look at his dad
and see what life would
be like 20 years from now.
He was able to
look at his grandpa
and see what life
was like in 40 years.
And so those two were in a very
similar situation as I was.
I was really interested in--
I wouldn't even say art,
but just being creative.
But I had this inability to
articulate what being creative
meant to an occupation.
And so when I told my parents,
I want to do something creative.
The only thing I could get
out of my mouth was painter.
And that was the
only artsy people
that I was exposed
to in my community.
And I remember my parents just
totally like, yeah, you're
going to be poor and homeless
and live under the boardwalk
if you're a painter.
And I used to think that that
was really a painful comment.
But now that I really
reflect back on it,
it was so accurate because
I'm a horrible painter.
I really can't-- my six-year-old
daughter can paint much better
than I can.
It was just that I didn't
understand how to articulate
something different.
And so when I was
looking at school,
was looking at trying to
figure out what to do,
I just totally abandoned that
interest in being creative.
And I listened to that societal
expectation of be successful.
And I majored in
business because I
thought that's what
you're supposed to do.
Just go do something
that makes a lot of money
and you'll be fine.
And it was about the time when
I was getting ready to graduate.
I was literally
just a few months
from becoming the
consultant, which
was like the assembly
line of everybody
in my business major
were consultants.
And I realized at
a career fair when
I was passing out
my resume that I had
no idea what a consultant does.
And so I asked this
guy, like, hey,
could I just take
you out to lunch
and learn about what this thing
is that I'm about to become?
And the only thing I
remember from that lunch
is he was wearing a suit.
And obviously by my
dress today, suits
do not connect with who
I am as an individual.
My blood was draining the entire
lunch because I just realized
this whole thing
that I had expected
that was easy to answer at
the family barbecue of like,
I'm going to be a consultant.
All of that just withered away.
And so Mike, Brian, and myself
all had this instant moment
right about the
time of graduation
where we just
realized this is not
going to work for ourselves.
And so when we talked
about what are we
going to do with our
lives, the answer to that
was really simple.
It was just, we've got to talk
to people that have already
figured it out.
Who out there has combined
interests and actually
figured out a life
that they love?
And so we literally just
thought, let's travel around
the country.
How do we do that?
We can't afford hotels.
Cool, we'll get an RV.
So this is our
beat-up 1985 green RV.
We painted it green with
paint from Home Depot that
was on sale.
We literally just rolled it on.
It's just caked over the
blinker lights and everything.
It really was unsafe.
And then we started
just cold-calling.
We had no connections.
The idea was just anybody
who sounded interesting,
we wanted to talk to them.
And we spent about almost a
year putting this road trip
together, just sitting
at mom and dad's house,
cold-calling all day long.
So I booked an interview
with Sandra Day O'Connor
from the 1-800 number on the
tours and information website
for the Supreme Court.
I cold-called Michael
Dell from the 1-800 number
on a commercial where you're
supposed to buy your computer.
My fax cover sheet
was my face placed
against the glass of
the copy machine--
to Michael Dell-- just trying
to stand out in some silly way.
Mike called the director
of "Saturday Night Live"
every three days
for three months
until she finally
picked up, on stage
getting ready for rehearsals
of the MTV Music Awards.
And we just hounded all
of these different people
that we thought were
really interesting.
And that road trip was
really exceptional for us.
It started as this
simple idea that we
were going to try and
figure out our own life.
But what changed was-- probably
two weeks into that road trip,
we realized it was
so much different.
It was much bigger.
These conversations
that we were having
needed to go beyond our lives.
So from that first
road trip, we've
been spending the last 15
years-- since 2001-- committed
to this idea of sharing
with other people
how other successful
individuals have defined
their own roads in life.
And so I want to
just walk you guys
through how that's evolved.
The first piece-- when we came
back, we had all this footage.
We had never edited anything.
We had never filmed anything.
But we thought the best way
to share an experience is
just to film it.
So we learned how to
edit with a manual
from Barnes & Noble
on Final Cut Pro.
We learned how to film
from people's advice.
And ultimately,
that first road trip
became a one-hour special
that we put together.
It aired on maybe eight
public television stations.
But it really started to grow.
And so we decided in 2003
that we would shift and put
other people on the road.
So our road trip
was the only one
we were in front of the camera.
Every year after
that, we've been
putting new groups
of road-trippers
out to interview new people
who they really connect with.
So this is just an example of
what it's evolved to today.
We're in pre-production
on Season 13 of the series
on public television.
We've done 116 episodes so far.
About 85 different road-trippers
have road-tripped with us.
So it's been growing.
We think we're in RV number
11 in terms of purchased,
three currently working.
The original RV is [? in ?]
our conference room.
We had an RV in
Australia, New Zealand.
We've done road trips in
Israel, all different places.
This is the interview archive
that we've put together.
So if you look at
that show, if you
look at 116 episodes
of content, we really
thought that there's got to be
a really dynamic way to explore
this rather than just episodes.
So we started to pull out
every single interview
and put it up online.
And so right now we've got
about 425 of the interviews
that we've got up there, a
couple thousand videos all
encompassed in that.
And it's people from all
different walks of life.
And we've got schools.
In 2008 we started a nonprofit
that takes this content
and turns it into curriculum
for high school students.
And just to give you an idea
of the types of people that
are in this archive--
If you just think
about the Craigs,
we interviewed
Craig Newmark, who's
the founder of Craigslist.
We interviewed Craig Brewer.
He wrote and directed
the film "Hustle & Flow."
We interviewed Craig Venter.
He is the guy who
decoded the human genome.
And Craig Robinson, who's
the former educator,
comedian on "The Office."
So I wanted to
just show you guys
what one interview looks like.
This is an interview with a
team that we put on the road--
actually from Oakland.
You'll see them twice
in this presentation.
And I think it's really exciting
to just look at one snippet.
This is just three minutes
of Andrew Lins' story.
And what you'll see
is a conversation
that's much deeper.
We're not asking him, how
much does a conservator make?
What was your
necessary education?
That stuff we can find
online thanks to Google.
We wanted to know the
deeper questions, like,
did you always know
what you wanted to do?
How do you value
your sense of self?
What did you do with risk?
And how did you
find an occupation
that relates to your interests?
And so this is just a
little glimpse into one
of our interviews.
KISURA HENDRIX: I feel
like personal with this.
Nobody gets to do this.
ANDREW LINS: You're right.
You're going to be one of
maybe 25 people to get up here.
KISURA HENDRIX: Yeah.
Isn't that cool?
That's cool.
And that's your job.
And I think that's just
I think that's amazing.
ANDREW LINS: When
I was your age,
I was thinking of two careers.
One was medicine
and one was art.
I decided medicine, my
parents would approve of.
Art, no.
So I took a job
first as an orderly.
I helped with the autopsies
and stuff like that.
And then I had a
bad car accident.
I drove a car over a bridge.
That took a little
while to get over.
And I reconsidered what were the
most important things in what
order and what would
give me the best
feeling of having done
something with my life
that I wanted to do.
So I said, well, I really
always have loved art.
So I spent several years
doing art after that.
I ran into a professor who
was teaching Baroque art.
He said, well,
have you ever heard
of this profession
of conservation?
They seem to combine
art and science.
I said, well, I
better look into that.
So I went to New York and
talked to several people there.
And then I ended up doing that.
KISURA HENDRIX: You
have been told to us
as being one of the
best conservation
people in the country,
if not the best.
ANDREW LINS: [INAUDIBLE]
I'm going to get
into a lot of trouble now.
KISURA HENDRIX: I
mean, I'm just saying
that coming from you wanting to
go into the medical profession
to please your parents to
doing this, which is completely
different, are you glad that
you went down the path that you
did instead of going
to be a doctor first
You know what I mean?
ANDREW LINS: Yeah.
I'm glad the more I
reflect back on what
I've done that I
made the choice I did
because this profession, for me,
satisfies all the things that I
think are important that
I have the skills at.
No matter what you do, you got
to use as much energy and brain
power as you've got to do
it as well as you can do it
all the time because you
don't get the seconds back.
You don't get the minutes back.
You don't get the days
back that have gone by.
And there's so
many things to do.
Do them as well as
you possibly can.
Take it all out and make
it as good as you can.
But do the things that
make you feel like you've
spent your time well.
At the end you'll be happy,
if not proud, of your life.
That's what I think about
more as I get older.
What are you going to think
when you finally have to answer,
was your life spent well enough?
NATHAN GEBHARD: So that's
just a little glimmer
into what these
conversations are like.
The average interview is
probably an hour and a half,
I think.
When we interviewed the first
photographer for "Rolling Stone
Magazine," it was a 2 and
1/2 hour interview marathon.
But it's really amazing to
just get in these people's
very personal stories.
And I think some of
my favorite moments
are those places where you
watch somebody lean back
and pause and say, I haven't
thought about this in years.
And you really get
down to the core
of who these individuals are.
It's been exciting.
If you look at where
we've started to now,
we've done we've
probably traveled over
120,000 miles across the
[? countries ?] back and forth
many times.
We're upwards of probably
just over 1,000 interviews
that we've conducted.
And all of this content
has been just in our head.
And it's been sequential in
terms of the television series,
in terms of the curriculum.
When we started to think--
about two years ago-- about what
would a book be like,
we really started
thinking-- we did not want to
write a book about our story.
We didn't want this
anecdotal thing of like, hey,
we did this road trip.
We figured out our life.
As long as you take a road
trip too, you will as well.
It was like there's so many
of the me-too five-point step
solutions that guarantee
success after 100 pages,
or something like that.
And we really didn't want that.
We wanted something
that encapsulated
thousands of
conversations and hundreds
of hours of interviewing.
Actually, that's the
other way around, right?
So we ended up starting about
two years ago on a book.
It just came out.
And I wanted to show you
just a little bit of a piece
that we put together
for the book.
And then we'll dive in [? for ?]
the rest of the session on it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: The reason
why I went on this road trip
is to talk to a bunch of people
who have made careers out
of something that they love.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What were
you doing in your 20s
or in college?
What were you thinking?
MALE SPEAKER: Did you
really not feel pressure?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Your family
expects so much of you.
Society expects so much of you.
MALE SPEAKER: How do you
bridge that gap between what
I want to do and doing it?
FEMALE SPEAKER: As I've
been going along this trip,
I've been really
trying to pay attention
to people who have
made something,
a lifestyle, a career,
when they haven't had
a blueprint, because I feel
like I don't have a blueprint
and I'm just trying
to figure it out.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's OK.
This is all a part of
an evolution that's
building me to go somewhere.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Well, I'll
tell you this story.
I sort of see it
as your future self
is leading you in some sense.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The 20s, to me,
it's about having experiences.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE] very
important thing I want to tell.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
encourage young people
to question everything.
MALE SPEAKER: It's the
journey that [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Success
isn't magical.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
It's like a trip.
MALE SPEAKER: You just
have to run after it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What is it
that's going to make you happy?
FEMALE SPEAKER: This was
a 45-minute conversation,
and it changed my entire life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATHAN GEBHARD: I think if I
could articulate the hardest
thing about putting
this book together,
it was that we wanted to
honor the reality of how
people figure out their lives.
And we didn't want to gloss
over the complexity of it.
So to give you a perfect example
of this, within 100 miles,
we interviewed two
people, Deon Clark,
who's a nuclear engineer,
and Paul Salopek,
who's a two-time Pulitzer
Prize-winning writer.
And Deon Clark was
this engineer who
said the best thing you
can do is take a skill
and focus it and dig as deep
as you can in that skill.
And you will gain so
much expertise around
that that you'll be invaluable.
And you can take that
skill anywhere you want.
And then 50 miles, 100
miles later, Paul Salopek
had a totally
different experience.
Deon was a nuclear engineer
on a nuclear submarine.
So he was running a
submarine at age 19
with 30 people underneath him.
Paul Salopek had a totally
different experience.
He had explored all
these different types
of places in his life.
And he said the best
thing you can do
is go broad, to
have a great amount
of different experiences,
and to put those together
in a very unique way.
And so in 100 miles, we
have two people saying
the exact opposite thing.
And so as we put
this book together,
we were really trying to
think, how do we honor that?
How do we put that together?
And ultimately, we decided
to come up with this.
And it's what we call this
process of self-construction.
It's a circular process,
let go; define; become.
It's one that you repeat
over and over again.
And it's really
an open framework.
If software had an analogy,
this is an open source platform.
What we really
felt was important
here is this process that we saw
consistently across the board.
That people had this noise of
society, this peer pressure.
They ultimately had to let that
go before they could really
think about who they
were in their own right.
Then they had to define
what was important to them
with that noise away and
then actually become that.
And that only lasts for so long.
You do that, your life
changes, your values change,
your interests
change, and then you
have to pick that
process up again.
And so this has really been the
core piece of the book, let go;
define; become.
And what we'll do for
the rest of the session
is just walk through that.
And I'm going to try
and bring as many people
from the conversations
that we've
had into the presentation.
Everybody that you see here is
both in the book and then also
as part of the
book, you get access
to all of the video
archive of it.
So the first part is let go.
It's very simple.
It's just about stepping away
from all of that noise, all
of that static,
and really getting
to the core of who you are.
And a key part of that is this
idea of shedding the noise.
The noise as we define
it is everything
that comes at you in
a way that doesn't
take your own individual
identity into account.
It's that inauthentic
you should be a lawyer,
you should be a doctor,
you're not smart enough
to be a doctor, you could
never go to college,
you have to go to college.
It's all of these
different elements
that we're always
inundated from.
And they can come
from our families.
They can from our peers.
But they can also
come for ourselves.
That self-doubt is,
in many respects,
noise that has come
from the outside
and that we've
accepted it as our own.
And to just illustrate
an example--
if any of you saw "Boyhood"--
this is Richard Linklater.
He wrote and directed the film.
When he told his parents,
I'm interested in writing.
I think I'm going to be
a writer, a director,
they really scoffed at him.
And they said, no, this
family, we don't do that.
We're a family of
doctors and lawyers.
And I think they were
really well-meaning,
but that was their experience.
And the best that they could
think about from a writer,
he said was they
said, well, maybe you
could write children's books.
But he really had this place
of just realizing that he
needed to let that noise go.
And he really went
on his own pursuit.
He worked at an offshore
oil rig for an entire year
to save up enough money
so that the next year he
could move into a
small apartment,
buy as many film books and
as much film equipment,
and learn the art
of film on his own.
And that was his process
of shedding the noise.
This is one of my most
painful and favorite quotes
to illustrate the noise.
This is Glenna Goodacre.
She had her first class
ever in sculpting.
This is what her teacher said.
"I had a sculpting
teacher who told me
I was stupid, dumb, and
ignorant and couldn't
see three-dimensionally."
Glenna Goodacre is the woman
who sculpted the Sacagawea $1.
She's also the woman who
is most notably recognized
for the Vietnam Women's
Memorial in Washington, DC.
You can imagine what that had to
feel like for her and the power
that it took for her
to overcome that.
So as you guys just pause
for a moment, think what
is your noise?
What were those pieces that
came either from yourself
or from your peers that
really stuck with you?
And did those shape
your life, or were
you able to resist them?
As we look at
resisting the noise,
there's a couple
stories I'll share.
This is Caroline Thompson.
She's the screenwriter for
"Corpse Bride" and "Edward
Scissorhands."
And she had this beautiful
analogy that I love,
which is just the
noise is sometimes
these tapes in our head.
And we just have to eject
those tapes and put in our own.
We have to start writing our own
scripts as opposed to accepting
the scripts of other people.
And when we really
look at it, I wanted
to take you guys back
to that Oakland team
that we saw earlier.
This is Jeff Johnson.
They interviewed him
about 2,000 miles later
than the other
interview that you saw.
And he speaks
really articulately
both about the noise that we get
from others as well as the box
that we put ourselves in
when we accept that noise.
KISURA HENDRIX: I want
to ask this question
because, like I said, I've
wanted to go to law school
all my life since I was little.
And now I find that I don't
want to do that anymore
but instead I want to
take this path over here
and I want to do
something in music.
And I feel like I'm
giving up on law school.
So what is giving
up and what is just
deciding to do something else?
JEFF JOHNSON: Man, here
is the key to the cell
that you've created
for yourself.
What I'm saying
is, you ever wanted
to do something so much
that you tell everybody
you want to do it, you
share with everybody
that this is what
you're going to do.
And then now what you're
trying to live up to
is the expectations that you
created for everybody else.
So my mom and them is expecting
me to go to law school
not because they told
me but because I said
that's what I was going to do.
But the bottom line is
you created that cell.
Nobody else created it for you,
which means you got the keys
to say, you know what,
y'all, I changed my mind.
I don't want to do this no more.
And if people agree
or disagree, so what?
They don't have
to live your life.
They don't have to
go work every day.
They don't have
to pay your bills.
They don't have to
raise your children.
be the ones that
are responsible for your
light and your gift.
So if you decide that you
don't want to do that anymore,
then tell the people
who said, you know what,
y'all, some stuff
has happened to me,
and I don't want to do this.
And you've got to
be honest enough
with yourself to understand,
is this something
I was created to do, or is
this just something I like?
Is this something I
was created to do,
or is this something I think
is going to make me look good?
Because what I see
a lot of people--
a lot of young people
doing especially--
is they think that they
were created to do something
because they ain't
see nothing else
or they haven't
opened their minds up
to other opportunities.
But so often we
confine ourselves
to this little box of doctor,
lawyer, engineer, teacher,
business person.
Free yourself [INAUDIBLE].
This is my key.
ABEL HABTEGEORGIS:
I appreciate it.
[? JEFF JOHNSON: Thank you ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
ABEL HABTEGEORGIS: The
conversation, the wisdom,
everything, man.
[? JEFF JOHNSON: Thank ?] you.
NATHAN GEBHARD: What
I love about Jeff
is just the idea that we
put ourselves in the box.
And as we looked at how
we wanted to round out
that first section of let go.
It really ends with this chapter
called "The Blank Canvas".
And the take there is if we
really accept that noise,
we're living a life
of paint by numbers.
And the more we can strip away
and wash those instructions
manuals away, the more we can
really start from a clean slate
and really think
about who we are.
And so that's how we end
that process of let go.
And that brings us into define.
I think the thing
about define for us
is that-- I think before
we started on the road trip
we had this expectation that
all of these different people
had always had it figured out.
So when we sat down with
Howard Schultz from Starbucks,
we figured he always knew
he was really into coffee
and he just knew how to do that.
When we sat down with David
Neeleman, who started JetBlue,
we just figured that guy,
he's all about planes,
straight line to success.
Wanda Sykes, same thing.
She probably was the
funniest person in her class,
always had confidence
up on stage,
and she killed it every time.
After those
interviews, we realized
that Howard Schultz was
the first in his family
to go to college.
And in college he was so
poor he was donating blood
to have enough money to eat.
You hear David Neeleman talk
about being an executive vice
president at Southwest
Airlines and then being fired
and how devastating
that was for him and how
he had to rebuild his sense
of self and his identity
and what he wanted
to create, which
ultimately resulted in JetBlue.
And we learned that
Wanda Sykes for years
was working at the NSA.
That was her way
of paying the bills
while she gained this
confidence, while she
became a comedian.
And so it was a really
eye-opening piece to us
to think that people didn't
just become instantly.
They moved in incremental steps.
And I think a great example
of that is this guy.
He is one of my favorite
interviews of recent.
His name's Adam Steltzner.
When Adam was first
looking around,
the only thing he knew he was
interested in was nothing.
He had no driver.
He was not particularly
compelled by anything.
He would start things
and then back off them.
He isn't sure if he
graduated from high school.
He was one grade
away and decided,
I just won't go back and check
those transcripts to see.
And at the point of his
story really starting,
he said, I was
playing in a band.
And every night I was driving
home over the Bay Bridge,
and I noticed that the
stars moved in the sky.
And he says this in an
admission of ignorance and irony
that he had no idea that
the stars moved in the sky,
that the moon is in a
different place each day,
that Orion is not here, but
it's there the next month.
And so on that simple little,
why do the stars move,
he decided to go to
an astronomy class
at a local junior
college, and just say,
I'm going to figure this out.
Why?
And it just bit.
That was an interest--
this idea about space
and how these things
come together,
how formulas can really governed
the rules of how things move,
both in space and on earth.
And he just started
to follow that.
And that was a drip, and then
the next degree was a drip.
And he all a sudden
finds himself enraptured
by this interest of the stars.
He lands a job at JPL.
And he starts
engineering landings.
He became the go-to guy
for complex problems
about how to land
things in space.
And to start from the guy that
didn't know the stars moved,
he ultimately was the one
that engineered the landing
or led the landing on
the Mars Curiosity Rover.
So when you saw that-- what
was it-- they called it,
I think, seven minutes of
terror, that was his team
putting that together.
And he's ultimately responsible,
him and the team at JPL,
for landing that rover.
And it just was such an
empowering piece for us
to realize people didn't
always have it figured out.
And I think that his
story is so much more
consistent than the very few
minority of the individuals
that we met with that
said, oh, I always
knew I wanted to be a writer
and I just became a writer.
That is the almost 0%.
And I think that really ties
into this idea of career.
From our perspective,
from all these
1,000 plus interviews,
what we really see
is that our current way in
which we approach career
is like taking binoculars
and looking at it backwards.
If we look at that experience
of going to the career center,
more often than
not it's this idea
that you just pick an
occupation in the future
and then reverse
engineer backwards.
If you're in a career,
it's pick the next career
and then reverse
engineer backwards.
What are the skills?
What are the
degrees that I need?
But what we saw was the
total different approach.
The people that really
found themselves happy
and engaged in the work
that they were doing,
they followed a simple thing.
And it was just a
simple piece, which is
they followed their interests.
This is Richard Meier.
He was the architect
for the Getty Museum.
And he said, "When
I was growing up,
my parents had a
basement in their house,
and I had a drafting board where
I would make drawings and model
boats and paper airplanes.
I just liked making things."
He didn't say, I want
to be an architect.
I think for the most
part, when we say,
I'm going to be a
consultant, it's
to end that awkward conversation
at the family barbecue.
What we saw was
people really gaining
their own sense of identity
was when they just said,
I have this interest and
I'm going to pursue it
and I'm going to
see where it goes.
And so if there
was one core piece
that I would say that is
about "Roadtrip Nation," that
is about this book, it is
pursue your interests, not
an occupation.
And we have seen that
time and time again.
When we started to think
about pursuing the interests,
we also looked at how
to put that together.
And what we saw was this
idea of this framework
called the roadmap.
And that's ultimately what
we named the book after.
It's this idea that
you're mashing together
multiple interests.
Because when we
went to JDK Design,
we weren't just
interviewing a designer.
We were interviewing
the designer
that puts art on snowboards.
When we went and
saw Adam Steltzner
it's not just science
or engineering.
It's those combined
together with space.
It's all these people combining
multiple things together.
And what we started to look
at was more often than not,
there was something deeper.
There was this thing which
we refer to as a foundation.
So for me, like Richard
Meier, it really
doesn't matter what I'm doing.
I will be lit up
with almost anything
as long as I'm making things, as
long as I'm building something.
The interests that I have--
design and technology-- that's
the way I manifest it.
But making things,
whether it's LEGOs
with my daughter, a website,
a boat, anything, that's
really what lights me up.
And so we saw time
and time people
were finding their
own foundation
and then combining
multiple interests.
And so this is a really good
example of an interview--
just up the road-- from Anna.
ANNA HORJILLOSA: I
went to UC Berkeley.
And I started out as a
philosophy major and an art
major.
And then I took anthropology.
And then I thought, you know,
I'm going to do theater.
And after I got out,
I was like, I'm just
going to try to get a real job.
But I wanted to be in a
place that felt right.
And I applied to the
Asian Art Museum.
I applied for the program
assistant position
in performing arts.
And I have museum experience,
I had my anthro background,
I had theater.
It just came together.
And it was totally unplanned.
The thing is I never knew a job
like what I have now existed
or could exist.
I just sort of positioned
myself with things
that really felt right.
It's really a matter of
instinct on some level
and a broad plotting of things.
Your path is what
you make of it.
There are positions out there,
there are careers out there
that you can fit into,
but there are also things
that you can make yourself.
And you have to just trust
that you have something
unique to offer and to
be consistent with that
in your choices.
NATHAN GEBHARD: And what I
really love about her is she
is mashing these pieces up.
She's mashing up
anthropology, theater,
and in the context of a museum.
And to give you guys some
more examples of people
we've interviewed,
this is Peter Travers.
He's a film critic at
"Rolling Stone Magazine."
He's all about sharing stories
with film and journalism.
And you could probably
add in music there,
if you wanted, from
"Rolling Stone."
We've got Jessica Matthews.
She's CEO of Uncharted Play.
She's all about helping people
in sports and technology.
You might have seen her.
She was one of the engineers
of this soccer ball
that small rural communities
in Africa could play with.
And during the day,
while they're kicking it,
through the motion generated of
movement, it's storing energy.
And they can then plug an actual
light into that soccer ball
and use it as light in
their homes in the evening.
It's an amazing story.
And she is combining
science into sports
and helping people altogether.
If you look at Jehmu Greene,
when we interviewed her,
she was the president
of Rock the Vote.
She [INAUDIBLE] that
she believes in,
but she's not doing
that in the abstract.
She's doing it in
music and politics.
And when we sat down
with Ariel Helwani,
he was all about
accomplishing goals.
This was a guy who really
had this goal of getting
into MMA reporting, but
he was deathly afraid
of the limelight.
He was petrified
of other people.
When he was in college,
he lived in the dorms,
and he literally would wait
till 2:00 in the morning
to go brush his teeth.
He was that afraid of
people, but his goal
was to be a reporter for MMA.
I have no idea why he chose that
goal, but that was his thing.
And he started small.
He started in a
local radio station
where he could just put his
headphones on and his hoodie
and talk into the mic.
Then he started a
blog, added some video
to that blog of doing
interviews with fighters,
and all of sudden,
he is the guy at AOL.
He's one of the key
people in the MMA space.
Now I wanted to just take
a little bit more time
to tell you a story that
really articulates, I think,
a lot of what we've talked about
before in terms of shedding
the noise, in terms of evolving
this idea of drip, drip,
splash, and then
mashing up of interests.
So this is Jimmy Chin.
He's a skier.
He's a rock climber.
He's an adventurer.
He's a North Face athlete.
Probably a month before
we interviewed him,
he had just shot the photo
of the cover of "National
Geographic" with Alex
[? Hahn ?] just standing
on the ledge with no ropes.
So that was Jimmy Chin's photo.
But he came from a very
traditional family.
His parents were very
much focused on education.
And he did a lot of
things to make them happy.
He was an accomplished
violin player.
He really pursued
college in a place
where it wasn't maybe
necessarily the thing
that he would have chosen.
But he did these things
to make them happy.
And he said that the one thing
he chose for himself to do
was rock climbing.
And so he said after
college to his parents,
just give me one year.
I'm just going to climb for one
year, ski for one year, and see
what happens, and then
I'll go get that job.
I'll be that lawyer.
He literally thought that
there was three options,
just be a doctor or be a
lawyer or be a business person.
And I think all of those are
totally admirable occupations.
They just weren't
right for Jimmy.
So he said, just give me
time to live my piece first.
So he started.
And he started at literally
just this simply rock climbing.
And that interest grew.
And he was getting more and more
accomplished in rock climbing.
And then one day on a
climb, one of his buddies
was trying to learn
to take photographs
and wanted to start a business
of taking photographs.
And they were on this pitch.
And his buddy couldn't quite
get the angle that he wanted.
So he handed the camera
to Jimmy and he said, hey,
will you just take this photo?
Whatever you can,
just take a photo.
Whatever.
A couple of weeks went by, and
that friend came back to him.
And he was like, yeah,
yeah, I sold a photo.
It was your photo.
The only photo this
guy sold was the photo
that Jimmy took on that camera.
And at the time, Jimmy
was living in his car.
He was rock climbing.
And he got $500 for that photo.
And he just sat there and
he said, if all I need to do
is sell 12 photos and I can
live for the entire year.
And he just kept going.
It was just this pursuing
of this interest.
He lived in that
car for six years,
but his skills and his
interests were evolving.
It went from rock
climbing to high Himalayan
climbing to these really
extensive expeditions.
And then it even went further
to leading really complex
expeditions in remote locations.
And what's interesting
about Jimmy's story
at this point was
he said, you know,
I couldn't have led
these expeditions
without that education that I
had, without these experiences
that I've had before,
because people didn't need--
when they're going to go climb
a crazy peak-- you couldn't
get a team that said, OK,
I need one photographer.
I need one videographer,
one climber,
and then one operations guy.
You need somebody that brings
all of those things together.
And Jimmy, through
his experience,
through that pursuing
of these interests
and this step by step approach,
really created this place
where he was one of the
few people that could
take on some of these things.
And when I asked him what advice
would you have to people trying
to define their own road,
he simply used this climbing
reference, which I think
really applies, which is,
[? "Commit ?] and
figure it out."
He committed to rock climbing.
That evolved to photography.
That evolved to leading
these expeditions.
That evolved to videography, to
starting a production company.
And if you have any interest on
Instagram, check out his feed.
It's really inspiring.
So at this point, just
reflect on your own roadmap.
Imagine what are the interests
that you would smash together.
If noise was nonexistent, if
you really had that freedom,
what would be that thing
that you would take?
And this gets us into
the become piece,
the last section of the book.
As we started putting
this book together,
I think the worst advice that
I think I've ever received
and I could give to anybody
would be follow your passions.
Because I think there's
a huge problem with that.
It makes it sound like you
should know it already.
It makes you sound like this
thing is so big that you've
only got one passion.
It's like find that right
one partner in this world,
the perfect match.
And what we saw
was people did not
approach their life that way.
They dipped their
toe in the water.
A woman that we interviewed
over here at Google,
she said, you're looking at
me now in this occupation
and in the success that
I have, and you think,
I'm doing so well, but you
didn't see all the steps
that I got here.
And her analogy was beautiful.
She said, it's like
you're looking at somebody
who's swimming in cold ocean.
They didn't just run
in there and jump
and say, oh, this is great.
She's like, I ran down there.
I put my toe in the water.
It was freezing.
I backed off.
I ran in there.
I got down to my knees.
It was too cold.
I failed again.
I ran back off.
And eventually she gets to the
place where she's neck deep
and then she's swimming.
But we connect to these dots
that really aren't there.
And so this idea that you should
follow your passion-- passion's
the destination if
you do it all right,
but it's not an approach.
It's really following
your interests
and exploring that passion
and finding validation
where your interests
meet your skills.
Then you arrive at
that place of passion.
But it's just not a reasonable
bit of advice to give anybody.
And we have not seen
that come into play
with the people we interviewed.
I think the most apt
example of these baby steps
is this interview
that we had with Jad
Abumrad, the co-founder
and host of "RadioLab."
And he has this
great analogy that he
pulls called the adjacent
possible from science.
So we'll just tap into it.
ZACHARIAH COWAN: One
thing that comes up
a lot is we're
about about defining
our own roads as opposed to not
taking somebody else's road.
But how did you take it
to that next level of,
you need to be more open
to other options and things
like that.
JAD ABUMRAD: Let me get
abstract for a second.
I'm going to bring
in some highfalutin,
and you can tell
me to be concrete.
But there's this
theory in evolution
called the adjacent
possible, which
is that if you imagine
the primordial soup is
full of all these chemicals.
Arsenic was in there.
There's amino acids
floating around.
Those things aren't going to
suddenly bump into each other
and create a human
being, or even a flower.
So it's not part of the
possibility of that space
to create the flower.
But you can take an amino acid
and you can take a fat cell.
You can slam them together.
Suddenly you've got a cell
and suddenly that cell
has more possibilities--
a two-celled organism.
And eventually an amoeba or
something-- I don't know.
So you have to
ask yourself, what
is your adjacent
possible, in some sense.
Right now you're, in a way,
in your own primordial soup
of dreams, but you have to
think of your possibilities
in both the most expansive and
the most constrained-- like,
OK, you know, I can't
be Michael Jordan
but maybe I could go
play in a pickup game
and work on my jump shot,
something like that.
There's a way in which you
always have to ask yourself,
what is possible right
outside my border?
NATHAN GEBHARD: I think
that piece of possibility
is very in line with
everything that we've
experienced with "Roadtrip."
We had no idea how to film.
We had no idea how
to write a book.
But we figured there was
some baby steps that we
could take along the way.
The other piece that I love is
this quote by Veronica Belmont.
She says, "If you're really
passionate about a topic
and you want to
work in that field,
you should already be doing it."
And I think that that
translates and is
a main piece for the
chapter in the book
called Practice Shmactice--
the idea that-- what
your coaches would always say
is-- practice makes perfect.
And I think we would really
say that from our experience,
doing makes perfect.
There probably is no
such thing as perfect.
But it's the actual
act of doing.
If you want to be
an actor, you're
an actor the second you
turn that camera on yourself
and start acting.
If you want to be
a writer, you're
a writer the second
you start a blog.
If you're into editing,
start that now.
I think the world
has changed in a way
that the avenues to get
into something that you're
interested are right
in front of us.
We could open a store
on Etsy for free.
We can do all of these
different things.
There are many different ways
to engage in your interest.
And her point, I think,
is just so poignant
because we should
already be doing it.
We should already be
using every decision
that we make in tying that into
the interests that we have.
The other piece-- as we think
about becoming, is failure.
And this is a guy that we
interviewed, Craig Brewer.
He wrote a film called
"Hustle & Flow."
And the song in "Hustle & Flow"
was nominated for an Oscar.
And he was an amazing guy who
told us this story about a film
that he had shot,
spent $40,000 on,
and never-- it was
so bad he didn't even
pay to have it developed.
Can you imagine spending
$40,000 on something
and then just saying it's so
bad I can't go any further?
So this is somebody that was
really experienced in failure.
And if you ever see the
film "Hustle & Flow,"
it very much ties into
his own personal story
in a very dynamic way.
But he talked about
getting to failure.
And I think that
the idea of failure
is something that we
hear all the time,
like, learn from your failures,
learn from your failures.
And I know culturally at Google
this probably resonates well.
You guys are exceptionally
well at just rapid iteration.
But I think for the most
part, when we apply this
to our lives, learn from your
failures translates into avoid
failing, and then if
you do, just cover it
up by saying I'm learning.
And Craig takes a totally
different approach here.
He says if you want
to get to something,
you have to actually
seek out failure.
And I'll let him do the talking.
MALE SPEAKER: I wanted to go
into film when I was younger,
but I didn't feel
like I had what
it takes to become a filmmaker.
I didn't feel like I could put
out my creativity out there.
I didn't feel I had
the guts to do that.
CRAIG BREWER: Interesting.
MALE SPEAKER: So now I
feel like I could do it,
but I guess that's
the main question
for me is like-- one
of the main questions
is, what are my fears?
CRAIG BREWER: What
are some of them?
MALE SPEAKER: Fear of failure
is definitely always there.
CRAIG BREWER: Well, are you
perfectly clear on the fact
that you will?
Are you cool with that?
I mean, you know that you're
going to fail repeatedly.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
CRAIG BREWER: Yeah.
I mean, it's going to happen.
I mean, the only way that
you're going to get good
is if you fail.
So get to failing.
Get that process going.
Don't put that off
because it's going
to hurt more when you're older.
And what ends up
happening that I've seen
is people don't want that hurt.
And so they get
married, they have kids,
and then they blame
their families
and their circumstances
for the fact
that they didn't want to fail.
They didn't want to risk.
They didn't want to
feel that kind of pain.
So I say that if you want
that enrichment of success,
then get busy failing
because it will happen.
NATHAN GEBHARD: And when we
talk about which failures
do you choose, I
think most of us
think in this duality
of safe versus risk.
And we had this great interview
with Jonathan Poneman.
He was the founder
of Sub Pop Records.
They covered anybody or
managed anybody from Nirvana
all the way up to The Shins.
And he said, if you look at
making decisions between safety
and risk, the natural
inclination that we
as humans have is to
protect and not to choose
some risky things,
is to be safe.
And he said the
way he approached
life and the
perspective shift that
enabled him to make
those decisions
was to change the dynamic and
make the decisions not on what
is safe or risky, but on what
is necessary versus unnecessary.
For him, happiness
was necessary.
For us, it might be our
family is necessary.
Whatever it is that is
necessary versus unnecessary,
it's a much easier way to
look at a yes or no decision,
what things do you explore.
Those things that give you life,
those things are necessary,
versus worrying about
things that are risky.
To leave you guys with
a challenge today,
we thought just very simply,
reflect on your own roadmap.
Reflect on the thing
that drives you,
that the thing that you would
be happy doing no matter what,
that foundational element
and those interests combined.
If you were to shed
that noise and really
think about how all of
that could come together
in a dynamic way, very
simply just today,
what's your adjacent possible?
What's the small,
little thing that you
could do today that just
gets you one step further?
And it might be
that you're loving
exactly what you're doing
now, but how can you
take it further?
Can you follow somebody
new on Twitter?
Can you take a new class?
Can you explore some interest
that you've never had?
Whatever it is, break it down
into some baby, baby step,
and just go for it.
And to close it off,
before Q&A-- this
is how we closed the book.
If you open up the book, this
is the last quote in the book.
And rather than read it to you,
I'd rather her just share it.
So this is Staceyann Chin.
She's a poet and activist
we interviewed in New York.
STACEYANN CHIN:
Attempt the impossible,
do the crazy, stand
on a limb, and teeter.
I say, teeter away.
Reach, leap, attempt things that
everyone says can't be done.
Run, jump, move, walk,
get your crazy done.
You are your bravest self.
And when I say brave, I
don't mean the quiet courage
that it takes to raise a child.
I mean the courage to do
what no one else is doing.
These are the years
to climb a mountain.
to break an arm.
These are the years
to fall in love
and recover and fall in
love again and recover
and to make love in
100 different cities
and shave your head
and take a year off
from your life to
do something that
makes no sense to anyone else.
Do it, do it, do it
now, and live it.
If you want to
write, if you want
to make films, anything
you want to do,
you have to live to be
able to do it first.
So live.
Live, live, live, live.
Get it out of your
system, so that when
it is that you have
an ankle that is sore
and you have bills
to pay, that there
are no regrets behind you.
The heaviest thing you will have
to carry as you move forward
is regret.
Make sure you're not
carrying too much.
NATHAN GEBHARD:
So with that, I'd
like to bring up
my other co-authors
and field any Q&A
that you guys have.
So as a matter of
introduction here,
we have Alyssa, who
runs all of our copy,
Willie, who directs our
public television series,
Jamie, who's also a
director and filmer,
and Annie who runs all of
our educational curriculum.
So this is the team that
put this book together.
There's a much larger
team at the office,
but primarily this
was that core team.
None of us are writers.
We all do different things.
ALYSSA FRANK: Hey, hey,
let's be [INAUDIBLE].
NATHAN GEBHARD: Oh, OK.
Sorry.
ALYSSA FRANK: This is
how I pay the bills.
NATHAN GEBHARD: Aside from
Alyssa, we're not writers.
So with that, if you
guys have any questions,
we can jump into that or
I'm sure you guys probably
have some things
that I missed and you
can share that or share some
experience of writing the book.
I think a fun fact
here is that we really
wrote the book on a Google Doc.
[? Yeah. ?]
NATHAN GEBHARD: So
thank you for that.
We really appreciate it.
MALE SPEAKER: I had a question
about the interests element
of it because it also is to say,
oh, just follow your interests.
And a lot of people don't
know-- and especially when
I mentor students
and stuff, they'll
say, well, I like basketball.
It's like everybody's not
going to be in the NBA.
And there's not a lot of
those opportunities out there.
Getting into sports marketing
is really difficult and stuff.
So how do you choose
which interest to pursue.
And then also, how
do you identify
what interests are the passion
points or the strong ones,
I guess?
WILLIE WITTE: I'll start by
just saying the first thing that
came to my mind-- because I
think you're absolutely right.
That's an awesome point.
So I come from the public
television series side.
And so a part of my job is to go
through this pool of applicants
of young people that are
looking for what they want
to do with their life and
take them out on the road
and try and get into their heads
and capture their journeys.
And I think the biggest
element of that experience
and a lot of what we're
trying to do with the book
is to emulate this element
of that experience.
And that's the
exposure side of it.
And basketball's
a perfect example.
When we go to high schools and
we bring our curriculum out,
that actually comes up
maybe 50% of the time.
I want to be a
basketball player.
And one of the first
things that we tell them,
and one of the things that
is a good metaphor for what
happens no matter what
they're interested in,
is realizing how deep
that rabbit hole actually
goes within the
world of basketball
and how many different types of
jobs there are in that realm.
And so that exposure piece is
a huge part that comes from,
I think, pursuing
that initial interest,
and then seeing what
else comes around that.
And I think what Nate brought
up in the beginning, which
is the cyclical nature
of the roadmap experience
that we were trying
to come up with,
is go into which
ones do you explore.
It's almost like instead
of picking that one that's
going to be the one that
you stick with forever,
it's more like pick
that first one.
What's next?
What do you want
to try right now?
And then once you
get into that world,
you start experiencing that, a
lot of things will be revealed,
like, am I good at it?
Or, is it as interesting?
Is it sustainable?
All these things
will be revealed
to the point where at some
point-- like I have in my life,
I think like how most people
that we've interviewed
have in their
life-- they'll have
to step back and reevaluate
that and maybe think,
oh yeah, actually now
I'm interested in this.
So that's where that
cyclical nature comes in.
And I think that that's one of
the most comforting things I've
seen the road-trippers learn
when they're out there is,
oh, I'm not deciding
what I'm doing forever.
I'm deciding what I'm doing this
year, and I'll reevaluate that.
And like Jimmy Chin,
like so many people, what
I did choose, what
I did explore,
will become valuable
in some unexpected way.
But, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
ALYSSA FRANK: I think it's
also about recognizing
how your interests
intersects with your skills.
Because, yeah, I think a lot
of us think so myopically.
Like, oh, I like basketball.
I want to be Jordan.
Oh, I like rap music.
I want to be a rapper.
And I think that it's
about recognizing,
OK, well, maybe
with basketball--
I certainly couldn't
be a basketball player,
but I could write about it.
I could get into marketing.
I could design the ball.
There's just I think an
infinite amount of ways
to materialize your interests.
And it's not always
obvious, but you
have to just figure out
where they align together
with your skills.
There's a chapter in the book
called Skills Pay the Bills.
So obviously you have to attach
it to some economic engine
in order to have a career
that pays those bills.
MALE SPEAKER: So it seems
like a lot of the folks who
were on those road trips,
they were young people, right?
People who were right out
of college or early 20's,
that kind of age group.
Do you think that your
message changes at all
for people who are not that
young, who are maybe mid-career
or later in life?
Does the calculus change
as far as risk tolerance?
How do you convey your
message to people who aren't
in that same age demographic?
Or is it the exact same?
NATHAN GEBHARD: You go.
ANNIE MAIS: That's a
really good question.
And we get that question often.
And I think Nate
touched upon it too--
just the idea of
these inflection
points, and that whether
you're a middle school
student, someone who is just
entering college, graduating
from college, trying
to figure out,
is this first job of
mine right for me,
do I need another job, what am
I going to do next, all the way
to, oh no, I retired, but
I still have 30 years left
to live, what am I going to do?
I think whenever you're
at a place in your life
where you have to
start thinking, well,
what do I enjoy, and maybe
it's changed a little bit,
I think you can still
go back to this process
of let go; define; become.
And I know, Nate, you've spoken
a lot about just the risk then
and the change in
that equation that you
were talking about that what
if you have a mortgage to pay?
What if you have
four children at home
and you might not be able to
just pick up and get in a van
and go climb a mountain?
So it does definitely change.
But I think that's why we tried
to simplify the message of let
go; define; become, because you
can alter each of those three
words to fit where you're
at, at whichever inflection
point you're at.
NATHAN GEBHARD: I think you
hit the nail on the head
from my perspective, which
is that tolerance of risk.
Where we were at when we
started "Roadtrip," sure,
we could leave for three
months and do that deal.
Now with three
young daughters, I
don't have that flexibility or
that ability to take that leap.
A really good example of that is
this guy named Tinker Hatfield.
He came from a sports
family, but came out
and was working as an architect
and really found himself
wanting that sports piece.
And he didn't say, oh, I'm
just going to quit and start
a totally new life.
I think his approach was,
how can I take a lateral move
into the sports piece?
And for him, as he divulged into
his own interest, it was sports
and it was design.
And architecture's a proximity
to that, but it's not true.
And so what he did is
he literally just went,
well, maybe I can be
an architect at Nike.
And so he made
this lateral move.
And then once he was at Nike,
then he started drilling down.
And so it wasn't like, I'm
going to quit, make no money,
live in my car story.
It was, OK, I've got
these responsibilities.
I'll make a lateral move,
and then I'll move down.
And he is ultimately the guy
that led all of the design work
for all of Jordan shoes.
And he's now the Vice
President of Innovation.
And I think it's about
adjusting that level of risk
for that time in your life.
And certainly earlier and later,
there's those opportunities,
particularly as it
relates to family,
where you've got more latitude.
And sometimes those
leaps can be bigger
and sometimes they need
to be more incremental.
JAMIE ZEHLER: Yeah.
And one thought that I had
[? while ?] you were talking
about that-- and it's
not so much related
to risk-- but I think
working here and seeing all
these interviews, one of
the big things I've seen
is reevaluating how much you're
allowed to change who you are
in your life and at
what age you're supposed
to have it figured out.
And so lots of people who've
gone back to school at 30, 40,
50, and getting rid of
the noise that there's
an expectation of at 20 you
have to have it figured out
and that's who you are
for your whole life,
and opening up the
possibility of like,
it's OK to decide that
you're going to be
somebody else at 40 or 50.
And socially, I think that's not
really acceptable necessarily,
but hearing it over and over
again from multiple people who
have done it has, for me, broken
down the sense of one identity
for your whole life.
NATHAN GEBHARD: Pam Gaber is
a good story in that respect.
JAMIE ZEHLER: Yeah.
ALYSSA FRANK: Yeah, I think we
get so defined by our careers.
I think when you go to a party
the question is, what do you
do?
And it's sort of the sole
source of our identity.
But we all have this plethora
of interests that we pursue.
And the things that we
might be most interested in
isn't even the thing
we do 40 hours a week.
But I think we live in
a time where there's
unprecedented resources
to explore those things
and cultivate those
little interests.
YouTube tutorials,
lynda.com, there's
just so many resources out
there to take little steps.
And it doesn't have
to be a giant leap.
But I think that those
iterative, little things, they
accumulate over time and
can lead to [INAUDIBLE].
NATHAN GEBHARD: Well,
thank you, guys, very much.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]